est-ce que toi avec Cyril tu es entier
bah j'espère franchement comment ça se
fait que tout ce qui dit Cyril tu dis
oui voilà stop dis-moi ça et tu as tout
compris
[Rires]
ou pas
il te donne un or tu l'exécutes
au milieu du carrefour tu vas bah toi
aussi hein on parlait d'honnête tout à
l'heure tu te souviens
j'ai pas voulu en faire plus que tu me
cherches j'ai pas voulu intervenir parce
que Marco chargé de toi tout à l'heure
tu as parlé d'honnêteté tu te souviens
tu disais à Marco on peut réussir en
étant honnête est-ce que quand tu vends
8 fois le même documentaire à C8 le
Disney en changeant vite interview et
c'est pas combien
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi Mathieu c'est marrant parce
que comme tu n'as jamais rien fait
allez allez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose tu te rendrais compte
qu'ils sont tous différents avec un
angle
différente
toutes les foutu dans le cul
te intégrité
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que j'ajoute
non mais tout le monde se moque de lui
sur la place de Paris
est-ce que oh [ __ ] une seule question
vous me répondez honnêtement est-ce que
vous lui achetez parce qu'il vient
chaque année vous implorez à chaque fois
donc je sauve ma boîte de production et
attention à ce que vous répondez parce
que j'étais là quand vous a posé la
question
il te menace pas du tout il te menace
a très bien marché sur cible oui
[Applaudissements]
que ma boîte qui marche si mal comme
l'autre con le dit elle fait tourner 4
CDI et 20 personnes pendant que tu mets
ta petite gueule sur cnews pour gagner
du pognon moi je donne du travail à 20
personnes tu es venu travailler à qui je
n'ai plus de travail je n'ai plus besoin
pourquoi pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en vacances et qu'ont rien à dire que
j'ai pas regardé ton cnews
tout le monde est en vacances donc ils
ont pris les ringards alors le ringard
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
toi et ta famille sur cette génération
qu'on allait attaquer ce sujet pour que
ça crée un débat interne
calme et silencieux voilà
[Rires]
qui a fait du Mali là
tu as fait du Marco
merci merci
en tout cas on voit je rappelle que la
question la question était la célébrités
[Rires]
même sans alcoolis non la folie oui vous
pouvez le voir je vais peut-être me
remettre à boire
bonjour
les enfants j'encule mes raisons
[Applaudissements]
désolé
c'est lui qui m'a provoqué vous rendez
compte ce qu'il dit six ans
surtout calme-toi
c'est bon allez calme allez merci
vous allez me retrouver demain
alors pourtant cette discuter
beaucoup mieux tous les deux moi je me
suis dit avant ça m'avait
[Rires]